Let's take a quick look at how to deploy Python
3 applications to Google App Engine. I have
a Python 3 app that runs great on my local
machine, and I want to deploy it to App Engine.
All my dependencies are listed in my 'requirements.txt'
file. To deploy our code, go to cloud.google.com.
Sign in to your Google Account if you haven't
done so already, and then go to 'My Console.'
Make sure you sign up for the free trial if
you haven't done that yet. Now go to "select
a project" and create a project. Give your
project a name, and click "Create." Then,
go to the "Compute Engine" section and make
sure billing is enabled. If you don't have
the Google Cloud SDK installed on your computer,
see the link in the description for how to
install it. Create a file called app.yaml
with the following information. We are using
Python 3 and gunicorn to run our server. Run
'gcloud init' to login into your Google Account.
Now run 'gcloud preview app deploy' to deploy
your application. In a few minutes, your application
should be deployed. Go to the URL, and you
can see your application running on the cloud!